à ce temps ils vont déplacer la cible on
y va maintenant
ces évacuations avec d'abuzar n'a pas eu
lieu nous avons la fille du gouverneur
parce que je vais premier de la garder
en sécurité
à remettre se trouve à proximité
immédiate et vous venir vous surfiez
demande ce que ça peut être abonnés
absents ok soit aller où
on dirait que chauffeur a été coupée en
morceaux et traîné par quoi
[Musique]
il a complètement été attaqué par avion
parce que certains lions devienne leur
pays
mais tu rapportes a dit m qu'est-ce que
tu en faisais parce que les femelles
sont d'autres études vous voulez
vraiment planter votre tente ici
truquée
m
la gale
on verra